في قلب منطقة الكوارث في تركيا ،
يقوم هؤلاء الأمريكيون بمهمة لا
مثيل لها لم يعرفوها بمجرد أن
ضرب الزلزال متطوعين من
إدارة شرطة مقاطعة لوس أنجلوس
قالوا إنهم عرفوا للتو أنه يجب أن يكونوا هنا من
نوع الشيء الذي نحن عليه  نشعر بقوة
لأننا نتطوع للقيام بالبحث
والإنقاذ مرة أخرى في أمريكا ،
وبالتالي فإن أحد الأشياء التي
تحترق في قلوبنا هو الخروج إلى
هناك ومساعدة الناس إذا كان بإمكاننا أن
تستجيب Keys للأعاصير
وحتى أنها سافروا إلى أوكرانيا  لم
أر أي شيء بهذا الحجم قبل أن يكون
التدمير هنا أمرًا لا يصدق ، فهناك
أه نحن في مدينة واحدة
الآن حيث يوجد أه تعلمون أنه
يمكننا الذهاب إلى كل مبنى
ونعلم فقط أن هناك شخصًا
يحتاج إلى المساعدة هناك وليس هناك ما يكفي
الناس لمساعدتهم على الرغم من وجود
أكثر من مائة ألف من المنقذين
سيحتاجون إلى مليون وهذه
مدينة واحدة فقط ، نعم في صورة كبيرة جدًا
لتركيا يوم
الإثنين ، يساعدون في إنقاذ صبي يبلغ من العمر 17 عامًا ،
الحياة الثالثة التي أنقذوها هذا
الماضي  أسبوع في هاتاي المتضررة بشدة ، هناك
الكثير لنفعله هنا ،
كنا ننظر إلى كومة من Rebel
بحجم هذا المبنى خلفي ، ونحن
نقف هناك فقط على كومة من
الصخور كنا نعلم أن هناك مئات
الأشخاص تحتنا ونحصل على  بالنسبة لهم
هي قضايا شبه مستحيلة
حيث نشعر بالعجز
لأن الكثير من الدمار الذي
يشهده هذا الأمر يحطم قلوبنا ، فقد كانت هناك
أوقات
تعرف فيها السعادة الكاملة والفرح
بسبب العثور على الأشخاص ، لذا فهي
أفعوانية من العاطفة
لأنهم  هنا فقط لدعم
شعب تركيا الذين يعانون من
زلزالهم الأكثر دموية ، فإن
سكان تركيا
يفعلون أصعب شيء
اضطروا إلى القيام به ، حيث يتعين عليهم التخلص من
مجتمعهم وأصدقائهم وأحبائهم
وأحبائهم
بعضًا من الناس  الذين نعمل
معهم فقدوا أسرتهم بالكامل وهم
يساعدون في الخروج هنا وهم
يساعدون في التخلص من
عائلات الأشخاص الآخرين ، فلا داعي للتخلي عن
الجميع هنا يبحث عن
جدة تبلغ من العمر 70 عامًا فقط مهمة واحدة في
مدينة واحدة  في منطقة زلزال واحد هائل